i'm so
open and so um fragile
that like i feel like the world just
like permeates me all the time and that
results in anxiety and depression and
like confusion and loneliness and like
ups and downs dove cameron has never
shied away from being honest with her
fans and in her most recent instagram
post she confesses what she's currently
wrestling with i'm still figuring that
out too i would just recommend being
kind to yourself the post contains four
photos of a teary-eyed dove and a
lengthy note saying she's been
struggling with the concept of self and
the inner relationship to who i know
myself to be and my outer perceivable
self who i feel i have never known but
other people seem to what is
performative femininity what is my own
idea of what beauty is what is something
that feels natural to me and feels like
fun and feels like expression and then
what feels like i'm acting out of fear
of not being liked and loved and and
what is that line she goes on to say
that she's been crying a lot lately
covering mirrors and feeling that
sexuality and performative gender norms
societal rewards and identity are
throwing her for a loop my relationship
with beauty is complex i think that
beauty is a is
a bit of a performance
i think that the way
that we've gone so far in either
direction
for
physical expression
expression in our art
the sort of like extremes when it comes
to
beauty adding that social media and
branding and the constant broadcasting
of self and visibility of ourselves and
everyone everywhere is not optimal for
mental health clarity of energy or
relationship to our inner world she says
she shares these feelings not because
she has answers but in solidarity with
anyone on the same journey like if i was
to give advice divorcing yourself as
much as you can from the opinions of
others around beauty which doesn't then
mean that you have to like run away from
you know because then i know through
saying that people are like but there
are so many beauty standards that that
you fall into right but that's also
something that i'm you know as an ever
evolving human being i'm also looking at
that in myself i'm also working on that
in myself ending the note with emotion
is cool dysphoria is okay living as a
human is intense we are all holding
hands don't forget dove adds a little
more in the caption saying quote i hold
a deep-seated belief that who i am is
wrong i am not allowed to be just as i
am i am not meant to be here she wraps
up her message with this maybe the
spaces that are the least human can
become the most human if we want that
and we can all let each other take up a
little more space i love you dove's
candidness should come as no surprise to
fans the actress has a history of being
honest about her struggles with
depression and anxiety i think i was
depressed long before i was famous i
think i was anxious long before i ever
even moved to la um
i think that they obviously exist
everywhere as well as being skeptical of
social media i think we also have this
like cultural disease where we're always
encouraged to show
the most positive aspects of our mood of
ourselves of our life and like frame it
in that way and i noticed that growing
up you know it's always like how are you
and you're like
good like can i can can i honestly say
that i'm good and if i can i will say it
it seems like dove's mission is becoming
the truest version of herself and
sharing that process with her audience
it really took me a long time
to
stop feeling so bad about myself that i
needed the approval of everybody and to
start being like
i really only care about my own approval
and i don't want to be on my deathbed
wishing i had expressed myself in all of
my
entirety for what that means to me not
for other people
[Music]
you